[Music]
in a world that demands constant
Innovation and fresh ideas creativity is
a skill that cannot be overlooked
luckily studies show that creative
thinking can be learned and developed by
anyone I'm rich Burnett for wandrium and
in this episode of perspectives four
experts discuss ways to harness your
inner creative genius and to make it a
habit in your daily life
We Begin Now by looking at what some of
the most creative minds of our time have
to say about the creative process
[Music]
genius is two percent inspiration and 98
perspiration
before Edison the American Author
teacher and lecturer Kate Sanborn
similarly said that genius is
inspiration talent and perspiration
of course
perspiration on its own is not enough
you can try very hard and still fail to
be creative
in fact sometimes trying too hard gets
in the way of generating new ideas
because you become fixated on a small
subset of thoughts
Graeme Wallace founder of the London
School of economics and author of The
Art of thought picked up on this problem
and broke the creative process down into
steps back in 1926
these steps which he based on his own
empirical studies and on the words of
famous innovators and other creatives
continue to influence models of
creativity today
Wallace suggested that the first step in
creativity is preparation
Gathering relevant information honing
any necessary skills defining the
problem or goal and entering the right
frame of mind whatever that might be
this step is deliberate effortful and
conscious
next comes incubation where unconscious
processing comes into play
this is a somewhat magical stage that we
don't know that much about although we
do know that certain circumstances seem
important at this juncture both inside
and outside of the brain
we want conditions that allow the
prefrontal cortex to take a back seat
rather than be the main driver of our
thoughts
we want to be in an environment in which
it's safe to let our minds wander like
on a hike or in the bath
the key feature of incubation is that
thinking is neither deliberate nor
effortful with the Mind free to wander
Wallace noted that consciously engaging
in unrelated mental tasks might be more
effective during this step than
attempting to stop all conscious thought
entirely
which of course is very difficult to do
after allowing thoughts to percolate a
bit The Next Step illumination often
comes suddenly seemingly out of nowhere
this is the aha moment where the
solution or creative idea comes to
Consciousness clearly and well-defined
Wallace noted that you can't force
illumination you have to allow it to
happen rather than willing it to
the last step in the creativity process
verification is important but often
overlooked this is where we tweak test
and iterate the novel idea to ensure
that it is in fact the right solution
here we once again are engaging in
deliberate effortful work
the late psychologist mihai chikset
mihai who was credited with popularizing
the concept of creative flow further
divided this last stage into two
evaluation and elaboration
he suggested that elaboration roughly
equivalent to the iteration embedded in
Wallace's verification step is actually
the most difficult part of the creative
process and reflects the perspiration
part of Thomas Edison's famous saying
send me high cautioned against
interpreting these stage models as neat
depictions of the creative process
a person who makes a creative
contribution never just slogs through
the long last stage of elaboration he
noted this part of the process is
constantly interrupted by periods of
incubation and is punctuated by small
epiphanies
we'll Begin by looking at divergent
thinking this fundamental skill
and we'll examine four proven principles
for improving Divergent thinking ways to
improve your mindset your attitude
the key principle is to defer judgment
deferred judgment means to temporarily
suspend one's evaluation
now I said this is the key principle
the reason why I suggested this is the
key principle is that it's required for
all the others you've got to get this
one right or it's very difficult to be
able to adhere to the other principles
and guidelines
Neuroscience gives us some insight into
how deferring judgment works
you see we're creative we're most
creative when our prefrontal lobe the
self-monitoring part of our brain is
less active there's research that has
demonstrated the profound positive
effects of deferred judgment in fact one
of the earliest studies of the creative
process conducted by another one of our
founding faculty members Sid Parnes
he conducted a simple yet elegant study
we had two groups of students
they were given a challenge a real life
challenge to solve and asked to generate
ideas but the two sets of students were
given different instructions
one set was told to suspend judgment not
to evaluate their ideas as they were
generating them
the second group was told to come up
with good ideas to generate good ideas
and by suggesting good ideas this
communicates the need to evaluate
what they found at the end of the study
when they evaluated the sets of ideas
generated by these students is that
those who defer judgment who followed
that principle ended up generating twice
as many good ideas as those who were
told to generate good ideas
we'll move to the second principle of
Divergent thinking
it's called go for quantity Nobel
Laureate line is Pauling perhaps said it
best
he said the best way to have a good idea
is to have a lot of ideas see the notion
here is that quantity will lead to
Quality we want to leverage probability
the more options you have the more
probable you are to have a breakthrough
and this has been demonstrated through
Dean simonton's research Dean Simonton a
well-known current creativity researcher
he's looked at eminently creative
individuals and he's found that the
number of creative breakthroughs they
generate is directly related to the
amount of work they produce
let's look at the next principle
let's start off by playing a little word
association I'm going to say a word you
think of the first word that comes to
mind
salt
table
up
our minds are wired to make associations
in fact
it's predictable probably the words that
came to mind when I said salt table and
up you probably said chair one or excuse
me you probably said Pepper when I said
salt
you said chair when I said table you
said up
or you thought of down when I said up
it's natural
hearing a song brings back a memory if
you had that experience or as you look
around and you see something it reminds
you of something that you have to do
this occurs all the time our mind links
ideas together and this is a powerful
source for creativity
you see new ideas don't come from thin
air if there is a muse to creativity The
Muse is past ideas
the mobile phone the car the internet
clearly creative they didn't pop
full and complete and perfect form
they built off of past ideas
they came from ideas that were borrowed
and synthesized
this third principle of Divergent
thinking we call make connections
let's move to the fourth principle
it's called seek novelty
seeking novelty is about having dreams
it's blue sky thinking it's going big
it's trying out new things Alex Osborne
who created these four principles for
Divergent thinking said it's easier to
tame down a wild idea than it is to
invigorate a weak idea
what seems impractical today can be
reality tomorrow science fiction is full
of examples think of Star Trek in the
1960s in their communicators and today
we have mobile phones
so I always advise writers to schedule a
weekly creativity time
a minimum of half an hour every week
I like to go to my local coffee
establishment for this it's a time when
you do nothing but creative exercise
intending to generate ideas writing them
down
I like to do that with a pen and paper
by the way because that opens up another
part of my brain and I need as many
parts open as I can manage
so here are some of my favorite
creativity exercises the what if game
this is the biggie the the gushing
Fountain of creativity train yourself to
ask what if all the time driving down
the street you know I'll see a billboard
of happy people in a restaurant and
think what if there was a bomb under the
table
or I'll see a man in a suit standing on
the corner waiting for the light to
change and think what if he's a hit man
and his Mark is across the street in
that Arby's
you know if you are intentional about
this eventually your imagination will
train itself to do this on its own
usually when you're in the shower just
don't forget to write it down when you
get out
the first line game
Dean Koontz in his book how to write
best-selling fiction written in 1981
told how he used to do this all the time
in order to find material
so one day he wrote this line
you ever killed anything Roy asked
he stared at it a while and then decided
Roy was 14 and talking to a younger boy
and that one line
he developed became his early bestseller
the voice of the night
now I love first lines and I have a file
dedicated to a bunch that I've made up
I can think of three right now that have
led eventually to books
one example is a novella I wrote called
framed it came about this way I was
playing the first line game and I wrote
it's not every day you bleed to death
I had no idea who my character was or
how he got into the implied predicament
so I started to play with it how could
this have happened
was it a suicide attend or or murder
attempt did my character have a a
near-death experience
could he be narrating from the Beyond
I kept asking myself what if questions
and writing things down and eventually
came up with an explanation that I liked
and from there I proceeded to develop
the story
news flashes
there's always something going on in the
news of course and if you're into
Political or crime Thrillers there's
always lots of fodder for those
the great TV series Law and Order
constantly mined news stories and
fictionalize them
but go beyond that
find the personal Stories the the local
items the odd news
in Hollywood some years back a very
large man in a convertible was pulled
over for drunk driving
it was Christmas season
and he was full of tequila but the odd
thing was that he was dressed only in a
Santa hat and a g-string
I had to use that and it became the
beginning of my novel try fear
so collect these throw them in a file
indeed one General piece of advice for
boosting creativity that's been
supported by many different studies is
to be happy
if you're depressed sad distressed
anxious anything but happy your creative
abilities seemed to be compromised
listening to happy music will boost your
creativity while you listen to it and
for at least a few minutes after but in
general everyday happiness will boost it
on a more long-term basis
as you prepare to undertake a
challenging task one for which you want
to Marshal your most creative thinking
it's worth starting by doing something
that makes you happy
one task that's associated with boosting
happiness as well as creativity is
walking many great thinkers have been
regular Walkers Charles Dickens claimed
that he walked about 30 miles per day
while thinking about his writing
Darwin Aldous Huxley Winston Churchill a
lot of great thinkers have talked and
written about mental benefits of walking
Friedrich Nietzsche the famous
philosopher once wrote that all truly
great thoughts are conceived while
walking
a tradition that goes all the way back
to ancient Greece in the so-called
peripatetic School literally the walking
School founded by the followers of
Aristotle
so the recent research provides solid
evidence for this belief if you want to
be a more creative thinker take your
thoughts and yourself out for a stroll
while you're on that stroll indeed even
when you aren't it's a good idea to
carry a pocket notepad and a pencil
the best creative thinkers tend to be
people who engage in a wide variety of
tasks
if you feel stuck with a particular
problem or set of challenges and want to
develop more Creative Solutions to it
going and trying something new can help
doing so can stimulate your brain in
novel ways indeed this is probably the
reason that going for a walk outside or
even being pushed in a wheelchair
outside boosts creative thinking as your
senses and body are stimulated with a
wide variety of different inputs the
internal state of your brain's
activation will tend to vary more as
well
finding a creative connection between
two pieces of information will only
happen if the brain circuits that encode
those two pieces of information are
active at the same time or at least
nearly the same time
if you increase the variety of ways in
which your brain is stimulated this
increases the chance of these unusual
co-activations taking place another tip
that's associated with improved creative
problem solving and creative work in
general is ironically to do nothing
at least not right away
just take some time to think about the
problem or your general goals before you
seriously undertake the work of
addressing them
notice that this is also good advice for
dealing with procrastination
ironically here I'm suggesting that you
do engage in a little delay in order to
boost your creativity
doing nothing for a little while is good
advice for overcoming procrastination
but for the purposes of creativity
there's good evidence that doing nothing
can also help avoid the opposite problem
known as pre-crastination
procrastination is the tendency to Begin
work on some important tasks for the
sake of getting it done for the sake of
getting it done and out of the way
even when that immediate commencement of
work is detrimental to overall success
procrastination of course is the
tendency to delay work on some important
task even when that delay is detrimental
to success and even General happiness of
the procrastinator
across a wide range of different types
of problems easy hard short long taking
a break and getting away from the
problem seems to help in finding a
creative solution to it
if you're stuck trying to find a
creative solution to something the clear
tip here is to work at it for a while
but then take a break
several studies suggest that if you can
include some sleep and some dreaming
during that break time the effects are
significantly enhanced if your
incubation period includes a night of
sleep during which time you will dream
you'll be even more likely to solve
problems like this or whatever problems
you're trying to address with your
creative brain
my last tip for boosting creativity is a
tip to enhance your memory of your own
dreams
try keeping a dream journal
as during other times of the day have a
notebook on hand next to your bed with a
pen and a dim NightLight you can turn on
in the middle of the night
most people awake with a memory of a
dream at least sometimes when that
happens grab the notebook and jot down
some notes about the dream you just had
then go back to sleep
the experience of reading those notes in
the morning can be just plain fun
which itself can be kind of a boost for
creativity remember that the moment your
dream ends it begins to rapidly fade
from your memory
the notes clearly written by you but
about something that you don't remember
in detail is a strange thing when I've
read my own notes in this this situation
I occasionally get the strange feeling
that someone else wrote them most people
think of creativity as unbridled thought
of waiting for an inspired solution to
Simply arrive the tips I've described
here will all help with your creativity
but they won't work in isolation if you
listen to Happy music incubate your
thoughts across the night of sleep give
yourself time to think before you start
working even if you do all of those
things you'll still need to invest
effort in searching for creative ideas
and solutions
if you invest both your inspiration and
your perspiration that's creativity
[Music]
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria